all right hi everyone my name is Lincoln
step and I'm from the department in
anatomy and neuroscience the University
of Melbourne in Australia
and I'll be talking to you today about
the work we've been doing on developing
a stem cell therapy for gut motility
disorders with a particular focus on the
paediatric enteric neuropathy
hirschsprung disease so first is a
little bit of background the enteric
nervous system is made up of many
different functional types of neurons
and glia and it plays really important
roles in the control of gastrointestinal
motility blood flow and secretion as you
can see in this whole map preparation of
the mouse and neonatal Mouse intestine
each of these blue dots represents an
inter neuron it's actually a really
extensive network of neurons and it's
known it was actually more neurons in
your gut than there are in your spinal
cord
developmentally the enteric nervous
system is derived from neural crest and
in particular from the vagal region of
the neural crest this is from the neural
tube
Jason percent marks one to seven and
during the early stages of development
these vagal milk wrestled emigrate from
a neural tube and enter the developing
for gap
they then migrate within the gut tube
within the gut wall in a rostro to total
direction to colonize the entire
gastrointestinal tract and you can see
that really beautifully on this right
hand panel where you can see a embryonic
day 10.5 mouse embryo where all these
neil crest cells have been labeled with
an antibody against the transcription
factor sock stem and you can see this
really beautiful stream of vagal neural
crest cells emigrating from the neural
tube
entering the floor gut and then
migrating within the duct tube to
colonize the GI tract here we can just
said time course of this colonization in
the mouse so the cells enter the
foreground embryonic Dave nine point
five and I don't reach the end of the
hind gap in the mouse until embryonic
day fourteen point five so there's two
things to note about this it's actually
a really quite a long developmental time
courses about 25% of the mouse's
gestational period and in here meant to
that twelve and half percent of the
human gestation period also note such
you'll note that containing the gut to
Betty 10.5 14.5 you'll note these cells
are migrating along an ever-growing gut
tube so we think they actually migrate
the furthest distance of any embryonic
cell and so if you combine this long
migratory route as well as this long
time course you have lots of
opportunities for things to go wrong and
this is exactly what happens in
hirschbaum disease where these migrating
neural crest cells just fail to colonize
the distal mass portion of the
developing bowel so hirschsprung disease
or congenital achingly enosis is
characterized but the absence of this
enteric nervous system in the distal
most portion of the bowel from the left
hand panel you can see this is an x-ray
of the first-run disease following a
barium enema and just to orient you you
can see there the two femurs and the
vertebral column and down the bottom
there is the anus and you can see just
above the anus this is this constricted
region of val is the region of doubt
that's missing in
nervous system and therefore has no
propulsive gut motility patterns
this results in inability of these kids
to pass through and the accumulation of
fecal contents a proximal to this
constricted region Abell and the
formation of what's known as a mega
Tolman and as you can see on this right
hand and all these kids usually present
within the first few weeks of life with
this massively distended abdomen so
Hirschsprung's disease affects about one
in four to five thousand live births
it's a multigenic disorder and
interestingly displays both variable
severity so some kids can have a very
short length of achingly enosis or
absence of neurons in their bowel and
some kids can have total intestinal
achingly enosis and when you're on
throughout their entire GI tracts and
for these kids life is very very tough
they're on total parenteral nutrition to
risk their life a little interesting Lee
also her sponsors that displays variable
penetrants so much so that monozygotic
twins can be dis controlled current
treatments at hirschsprung disease is
the surgical resection of this defective
a ganglionic portion of the bow and then
remaster gnosis or suturing of the
distal most normal ganglion aided part
of the bowel to the anus and while this
surgery is life-saving for these kids a
very large proportion of that have
ongoing complications for the rest of
their life including a fecal
incontinence and constipation and this
presents just not a large financial
burden on the families and on the health
system but also a huge psychosocial bed
man these kids as they grow up
so there's been quite a bit of interest
in the last few years in the potential
of an alternative therapy and that being
self there be to treat hirschsprung
disease and other enteric neuropathies
and so the idea would be to produce a
enteric neural progenitor cell for
example from pluripotent stem cell
populations or our group and others
around the world have shown that but in
both rodents and in humans there exists
a resident in Terra progenitor cell
within the gastrointestinal tract and
these exist out into adulthood and even
the normal and even the normal ganglia
native regions of Hirschsprung's
patients so the idea would be to then
isolate these cells enriched for the
appropriate skin or progenitor
population expand them in culture and
then Transplant them back into this egg
and we are effective portion of the
bowel to effectively create a new
enteric nervous system where one was
congenitally absent and the ultimate
goal of course would be to avoid this
really invasive restrictive surgery that
these kids have to undergo so well in a
mouse but we think maybe some
low-hanging fruit of cell therapy in
this context might be using these cell
therapy an adjunct to the current
resection and we may be able to help
avoid some of these post-operative
complications if these kids have to
suffer so in our lab we've been using
animal models to build a bit of a
roadmap to cell therapy for hirschsprung
disease and we've been using a number of
different animal models to touch on some
of these really important points shown
here on this slide but today I'll be
focused on talking to you about our work
using that mouse model to look at the
transplantation of enteric neural
progenitor and looking at their
migration differentiation and functional
innovation is about
we get a stem cells from so we isolate
and teraphim your progenitor populations
from mice where all the New York rest
drive cells expressing fluorescent
proteins and we isolate these from
embryonic so a 14.5 and postnatal p4
postnatal gap
we then dissociate the gut eyesight the
fluorescent progenitor cells using flow
cytometry and plate them into low
attachment plates where they form this
beautiful green neurospheres you can see
on the right after node these are not
URIs fears in the classic sense like a
central nervous system nurses are not
clearly derived so they will contain a
mixed population of stem cells
progenitor cells and also probably some
differentiate so
we then transplant these nurses into to
this we pivot we a week-old recipient
wild-type mice and then we live this
nice for up to 16 weeks before we come
back and examine what the stems that was
it being able to do so now this I'll go
through some of that previously
published data we were able to show that
these cells were undergoing
proliferation following transplantation
so to do this we transplanted our
neurospheres into the recipient animals
and then for five consecutive days
injected them with a Simon in analog edu
as you can see a large number of
aircraft drive cells are taken up edu
and then a population of these had also
subsequent we've gone on to
differentiate into sheer positive
neurons suggesting that they're getting
both proliferation and neurogenesis so
generation of newborn neurons from our
transplanted progenitor population
something that's very characteristic of
the enteric neural progenitor population
is a really highly migratory and so we
want to examine the migration pattern of
these cells after transplantation and
were able show that our graft or
ourselves migrated in a time dependent
manner up to about six to eight weeks
after transplantation so from a nearest
fear of no greater than 250 microns in
diameter the cells migrated to occupy
greater than ten square millimeters of
the nafs' intestine and then us
projected well beyond that occupy about
20 square millimeters of Anasta
against I mean that's not exclusive tube
it is characteristic of the enteric
nervous system is the neurons and glia
don't live in isolation they clustered
together in these ganglia and we found
that as their cells migrated away from
the draft site they coalesce to form
these ganglion light clusters which were
composed of xi+ neurons and there's 100
positive clear like in the central
nervous system there's a huge range and
variety of different neuronal subtypes
that make up the international system
but the two main sub subtypes of the ENS
are your nitrogen and your cholinergic
neurons which mediate relaxation and a
contraction of musculature respectively
and we were able to show that
subpopulation to that graph drive cells
are generated these nitrogen and
cholinergic neurons following
transplantation
this is very exciting we're getting
migration alliteration and
differentiation but really want to know
are the neurons that we're generating
from a stem cells following
transplantation are they functional and
today this Jamie former collaborator at
the University of Melbourne performed
interest early recordings from the graph
drive neuron so while Jamie was
recording from these cells she was able
to feel the vampire frightened and so
you can see in this left-hand panel by
sight and fills graph drive here on
showing predominantly they shared any
external morphology and they showed
lamella and filamentous dendrites which
is just indicative as they still be a
more immature or neuronal phenotype but
really excitingly general is able to
show that in response to a step current
in this little pen on the graph drive
neurons could fire action potentials
this particularly neurons provide a
single action potential but some of the
neurons could fire trained of up to six
or seven action potentials and on the
right-hand side the panel you can see
that they also received fast excitatory
postsynaptic potential indicating they
are able to receive synaptic inputs
so this is really exciting vagina
functional neurons in vivo but for a
cell therapy for a gut motility disorder
you don't need neurosis to be firing
action potentials and receiving inputs
you need them to actually functionally
innovate the gut smooth muscle because
this is where they'll control the
relaxation and contraction that drives a
propulsive gut motility patterns and to
ask whether our graph drives stem cells
generating neurons which functionally
actually functioning innervate the
smooth muscle dubrow we combined
optogenetic techniques and interests
early recordings again
now optogenetic technique our
optogenetic tools in particular is
channelrhodopsin which is the light
gated ion channel and so we isolated in
these experiments we isolated and turn
your progenitor cells again from
embryonic and postnatal intestine of
mice with a expressed both yfp as well
as this light gated ion channel channel
adoption we dissociated the gut isolated
this first themselves by flow cytometry
and generated these channelrhodopsin
expressing in tariff neurospheres again
we transplanted these into two to three
week old recipient wild-type mouse and
left them for four to five weeks
so after this four to five week period
our Rachel Grimm is working in a
laboratory at the time isolated disc
CAPTCHAs and opened out into a flat
sheet she then took intracellular
recordings this time not from our graph
derived cells but from the smooth muscle
of the gut and then she looked to see if
she could detect any responses in these
muscle cells to both electrical
stimulation which will serve as a
control that will stimulate all the poor
the endogenous neurons of the Bell and
also for Syria to detect any responses
in the muscle cells to the specific
light stimulation of aircraft arrived in
your arms
the
the data I'll give you a little bit of a
background about the neuronal circuitry
I'm allowing propulsive cup motility so
the first thing to know on this little
schematic is that all of these neurons
actually resided in the gut wall
so there are enteric nervous system is
made up of sensory neurons as well as
engineer on populations as well as these
a sending excitatory motor neurons which
mediate the contraction of the gut
muscle all to a food bolus like you can
see here and this is predominately
through the recent release of
acetylcholine on the right hand side you
can see they also these descending
inhibitory motor neurons which mediate
the relaxation of the gut muscle anal to
serve bolus an assistant Pro Don issue
the release of nitric oxide and ATP and
it's this coordinated contraction and
relaxation of the muscle which drives
propulsive gut motility patterns
including peristalsis
a little bit more information so the
electrical event within a muscle cell
underlying a relaxation is known as an
inhibitory Junction potential or an IJ P
and this is a hyper polarization of the
membrane potential of that muscle cell
conversely the electrical signature
within the muscle cell of a contraction
if the depolarization of the membrane
potential called an excitatory Junction
potential or an edge AP and you can see
why both of these DJ P's and our JP
traces of look like in the upcoming
experiments
Rachel look to see whether we were
generating any inhibitory Junction
potential or relaxation with our
stations from our graph derived neurons
so again you can see here this is
electrical stimulation which I'll remind
users of control because this will
stimulate all of the endogenous neurons
in the mouse intestine and not
surprisingly electrical stimulation
resulted in monitors inhibitory of
Junction potential which was reduced by
the addition of this p2y one receptor
antagonist mrs 2 179 which blocks the
ATP mediated part of the relaxation and
was then third was completely abolished
by the further addition of nola
which blocks the nitric oxide mediated
part of this relaxation
and really really exciting me for us we
were able to show that light stimulation
I'll remind you so this is selective
activation of our graph to write neurons
also resulted in these inhibitory
Junction potentials which had identical
pharmacology to these endogenous
inhibitory motor neurons
and here you can just see some of this
data quantified here to suppose the
federal nurse fee recipients and the
postnatal nursery recipients and while
two things to take away well
interestingly is a lot of out in
temperature Junction potentials appeared
to be larger in recipients containing
postnatal nurses competitive compared to
their seedling nursery recipients
regardless these results shows that
graph to ourselves contribute to
circuits would generate ijp
or gut relaxation
of course next week
see whether we were also generating
neurons which contributed to excitatory
inputs within these circuits and
excitingly again Rachel's labels show
like with electrical stimulation
specific light stimulation of our graph
driving neurons generated these
excitatory Junction potentials which
were blocked by the addition of this
masculinity receptor antagonist - and
these data show that these craft or
ourselves or this graph drive neurons
contribute the circuits that generate EJ
peds or gut contractions
the next next we wanted to ask question
what what types of neurons are we
generating with the new selected are we
making the inter neurons are we making
the murder neurons or are we making both
and to ask this question we decided to
target the financial trainees into
neuron and these inhibitory motor
neurons
so it's known that in the mass distal
column these inter neurons release
acetylcholine each act on nicotinic
acetylcholine receptors on these
inhibitory motor neurons and that this
synapse can be blocked by the addition
of a drug called hexamethonium
so when they should perform these
experiments she was able to show that
addition of hexamethonium resulted in a
significant reduction in the amplitude
of these inhibitory Junction potentials
following both electrical and light
stimulation we think this indicates that
there's a reduction in the amplitude of
IJ P by blocking the synapse indicates
that actually generating these graph
derives channelrhodopsin expressing in
two neurons in these circuits however
the fact that this response wasn't
completely abolished also indicates that
we're generating some of these graph
derived inhibitory motor neurons within
this circuit this is really exciting
we're generating all these proprietary
within this circuit a brand new and
tariff neural circuits so this is the
data that we saw when we looked at the
Federal European recipients what equal
measures shocked and disturbed when we
saw that addition of hexamethonium in
the post Melanie recessive recipient had
no effect suggesting the personnel
neurospheres did not generate
cholinergic interneurons
library at the University of Melbourne
Joel Bornstein and reminded us that
there is a population of pure logic into
neurons in the mass district alone and
that these release ATP which act on p2x
receptors on the same inhibitory motor
neuron in the distal column so when we
blocked the P 2 X 2 P 2 X 3 receptors
with a drug called TMP ATP we saw a
significant reduction in the ijp
amplitude indicating that while these
post-analysis don't generate their
cholinergic interneurons they do
generate pure energy into neurons
and here we just have the summary of the
electrophysiological experiments and the
takeaway is a very busy slide that
takeaways that a neuron stratagem is
isolated from the embryonic gut their
motor neuron and into neurons have
identical pharmacologist to the
endogenous neurons of mass distal colon
neurons derived from post-metal
from progenitors isolated from the
postnatal gap there are motor neurons
have identical pharmacology is however
they look to have limited
interneuron population
some conclusion hopefully I've been able
to show you that the entire gentleman's
transplanted into the column of
recipient marks a generative functional
excitatory and inhibitory motor neuron
whose farm ecologies match those of
noted native motor neurons
interneurons were also generated however
the age of the donut influences the
neurotransmitter phenotype
we think the generation of functional
motor neurons and interneurons
progenitors isolated from the postnatal
bowel is clinically really important
because it suggests that patient-derived
cells might be in a possible source to
treat our own disease and other enteric
neuropathies such as tikal Asia and some
forms of diabetic gastroparesis
you
and studies future studies are involving
transferring all of this experimental
inter experiment into a Hirschsprung's
model recipient mouth and also expanding
into larger animal models and also
looking at methods to analyze actual pop
the propagating motility patterns in
these recipient mice rather than the
interest of the recording electrical
signatures of relaxations and
contractions
- Thank You people my boss and mentor
Heather young
Marley and how Mikkola bed Rachel Green
and Jamie forms to perform the
electrophysiological studies which I
really think sets our were compiled from
our contemporaries we are hotter who
helped get this research off the ground
in the very beginning professor John
finesse from our department who helped
develop the surgical techniques for
transplantation and our collaborators at
the University and in particular motor
from Japan helped generate some of the
marsh used in the study thank you very
much